en el vídeo pasado vimos que si tenemos
una serie infinita donde cada término es
una función de n y si dicha función es
continua positiva y decreciente sobre el
intervalo que nos interesa y suponiendo
que esta serie converge podemos entonces
estimar el valor al cual convergencia
serie usando un número finito de
términos y un par de integrales que
pudimos construir pues cuando separamos
la serie en una suma finita y una suma
infinita dicha suma infinita la pudimos
conceptualizar de dos maneras por un
lado como una subestimación de esta
integral que tenemos aquí y por otro
lado como una sobreestimación de esta
integral que tenemos acá y por eso
podemos no tan solo estimar ese sino
poner límites a dicho valor si para una
serie dada podemos evaluar el lado
izquierdo aquí y el lado derecho aquí
tenemos entonces los límites para ese
pero veamos qué tan buenos son estos
calculando los para una serie en
particular
digamos digamos que la serie infinita a
la cual queremos aplicar esto
la voy a poner en amarillo supongamos
que s es igual a la suma desde n igual a
1 hasta infinito de 1 entre n cuadrada
supongamos que no sabemos cómo encontrar
el valor exacto pero queremos estimar lo
y digamos que queremos estimar el valor
de s usando los primeros 5 términos así
es que ese de 5 s de 5 es igual a la
suma desde n igual a 1 hasta en igual a
infinito no no no perdón hasta n igual a
5 de 1 entre n cuadrada y este valor es
aproximadamente igual sacamos la
calculadora para obtener 1 sobre 1 al
cuadrado que es uno más uno sobre 2 al
cuadrado que es un cuarto más 1 sobre 3
al cuadrado un noveno más 1 sobre 4 al
cuadrado un dieciseisavo más 1 sobre 5
al cuadrado que es 1 sobre 25 y esto es
igual a obtenemos este valor de aquí que
podemos tomar redondeando como
1.464 así es que es aproximadamente
igual a 1.464 y ahora evaluemos estas
integrales
tenemos que k es igual a 5 elegí ese
valor de manera arbitraria hubiera
obtenido una mejor estimación eligiendo
k igual a 10 ó k igual a 20 así como
hubiéramos obtenido una peor estimación
con k igual a 3 pero me pareció
razonable elegir que igual a 5 de hecho
no requería la calculadora para obtener
este valor lo podía haber hecho a mano
louis es simplemente para ahorrar tiempo
evaluamos entonces estas integrales
tenemos la integral desde 5 16 hasta
infinito de 1 entre n cuadrada de x y
esta integral impropia ya sabemos cómo
evaluarla esta es igual a esto es igual
al límite no lo voy a poner mejor en
azul
voy a mantener el azul el límite aquí
voy a introducir una nueva variable que
le voy a llamar
el límite cuando b tiende a infinito de
la integral desde 6 hasta infinito de 1
entre n cuadrada de x y esto es igual al
límite cuando ve tiene infinito de
veamos la anti derivada de esto es menos
n elevada a la menos 1 y vamos a evaluar
eso en b y en 6
así es que esto es igual al límite
cuando b tiende infinito evaluamos en
reynosa menos 1 sobre b y luego menos
menos 6 a la menos uno que es más un
sexto tomamos el límite el límite de
este término cuando b tiene infinitos se
hace cero y este límite vale un sexto y
ahora podemos usar el mismo
procedimiento para evaluar esta integral
así es que vamos a evaluar la la
integral definida más bien la integral
impropia desde el valor de k que es
igual a 5 hasta infinito de una entrene
cuadrada
de equis y si anteriormente teníamos un
límite inferior de 6 ahora nuestro
límite inferior es de 5 y esa es la
única diferencia así es que siguiendo el
mismo procedimiento el resultado de esta
integral es igual a un quinto y ahora
con los valores que hemos obtenido ya
podemos establecer la desigualdad
compuesta la cual va a quedar como 1.464
1.464 más de que esté usando una
aproximación de s sub 5 podríamos haber
usado el valor más preciso de la
calculadora tenemos entonces 1.464 más
un sexto más un sexto lo cual es menor o
igual que menor o igual que el valor de
s el valor de la suma que nos interesa s
que a la vez es menor o igual que 1.464
1.464 más un quinto más un quinto y el
lado derecho de la desigualdad es
inmediato pues un quinto es punto 2
así es que aquí tenemos que esto es
menor o igual
a 1.264 que es mayor o igual a s y para
el lado izquierdo vamos a sacar la
calculadora tenemos que el resultado
anterior le voy a sumar un sexto y esto
nos da 1.630 pero un momento aquí tengo
un error esto no puede ser a ver ahora
lo corrijo del lado izquierdo de la
desigualdad quedamos que tenemos 1.630 y
de este lado mi cerebro no estaba
funcionando muy bien esto debe de ser
este punto 2 en vez de sumar punto 2 así
es que esto es 1.664 1.664 así es que
con esto vemos que ese tiene que ser
1.63 y algo o 1.64 y algo o 1.65 y algo
o quizás 1.66 y algo pero aquí ya
tenemos bastante precisión si sólo nos
interesará un resultado a nivel de
décimas ya lo tenemos con esto ya
sabemos que ese es igual a 1.6
ya tenemos una precisión adecuada y como
puedes imaginar si hubiéramos tomado más
términos en la suma parcial tendríamos
aún más precisión espero que este
ejercicio te haya parecido claro e
interesante no tan sólo obtuvimos una
buena estimación de ese al usar una suma
parcial y la ayuda de este par de
integrales también obtuvimos un par de
límites
sabemos que el valor al cual convergen
la serie se encuentra entre estos dos
números